Okay. Sound's good.
Viki Slavin, how are you?
I'm great.
Good to see you.
So, where are you calling from right now?
From Tel Aviv.
I'm based in Israel.
But we are working from home.
So, probably you'll find me
in my living room.
I love it. I love it.
So, I think that working from home,
the true answer is, I'm everywhere.
Because now, there is no sense
in a specific point in time.
Viki, I can't wait to hear your story.
Right before we started this,
we were chatting a little bit about
both the idea of mentorship,
but also the idea of the responsibilities
of being an entrepreneur for a good impact
following this idea
of bootstrapping a company.
And I'd love to spend these 20 minutes
touching on these three subjects.
Because I think, they're fascinating.
And I'd love to start with the middle one.
About what it means to be
an entrepreneur to you,
and the privilege of being an entrepreneur
in terms of the responsibility
that we can undertake onto ourselves.
Okay. It's a good question.
I think it's always take ownership.
No matter if you are the expert
of a subject, or a topic,
you must take ownership
because it's yours.
And if stuff cracks between
if something goes wrong,
you need to step in and you can't say,
"Okay. It's not mine."
So, I think that's the main characteristic
of a good entrepreneur.
And a second, not to miss
a good opportunity if you see one.
But, you must say "no"
for almost everything else.
So, that's under intuitive.
Because when you think of entrepreneurship
a lot of the times I think of "yes".
A yes person, right?
Yes-and. Yes-and.
But you're saying that most of the time,
your responsibility is to say "no".
Yes, because you need to stay focused.
And you need to invest yourself,
it's not 100%, it's really 200%.
Because you must take yourself
out of the box.
You must be more creative
than you're expected.
You must encounter in many difficulties.
And many times it will tell you,
"No, don't do it."
"Why? Why? Why do we need it?"
And you must continue, probably.
So, you're an entrepreneur yourself.
Multiple time entrepreneur.
You're also deep
into the technology scene
and helping companies with
create better technology
through your most recent now
global consulting firm.
That helps them
write software that scales.
Talk to me a little bit about
what this business does.
And then I'd love to go back
all the way to the journey
of how you started it,
how you bootstrapped it
and move from there.
No problem at all.
What we do at ProdOps,
and if you pronounce it correct,
it's a production and operations.
How you can combine both of them.
We help clients to build
and deploy solutions.
To automate the cloud infrastructure
and improve the whole workflow
of how you deliver code.
It's great that you have code, right?
But until it won't leave in the real world
and people won't be able to use it,
it's worth nothing.
It's a backlog.
Okay. So, how do you actually go in
and help these companies?
Because sometimes,
companies that have a dozen engineers,
they have a lot of different systems.
They have a lot of internal conventions.
And it sounds a little complicated
for an external group
to come in and help them understand
what they have and deploy it.
We start from a process,
what they want to achieve.
Okay. Now, and what is the business,
let's call it impact,
that you would like to create.
You want to deliver a feature
that will create that wild moment.
Okay. Let's focus on your user.
Okay. And once you focus on your user,
we explain the flowback.
What do you have in your functionality
of your systems today,
that is good enough
and you can improve it.
And then, let's find ways to improve it.
Is it by a faster delivery.
Is it by creating better feedback loops.
To break feedback, you monitor stuff
and you can fix better.
Is it by scale to other regions
or countries.
And is it by use cloud better
and have the opportunity
to scale your systems
and provide good service
in different countries in the same time.
So, we look on the business outcomes
that our customers need.
We see what are the bottlenecks
that they have in the process.
And only after we achieved it,
we think if we can consult
on what do you want.
What practices do you want to be
about clean development.
Is it good for you agile development.
Okay. We are not agile mentors,
but we understand what does it mean.
And what does it mean for an R&D team.
So, it's not just
on the deployment, right?
What you're talking about here
is the whole pipeline of a company
that comes in and says,
"We have software that is helping us
create a service for people."
And you can actually interject
in any part of the pipeline.
Not just the deployment
to the cloud or to the user.
Exactly.
We don't have any, let's call it
added advantage in what you develop,
but how you bring it to your customers.
How you deploy it to your customers.
What is the process
to do it in a better way.
So, why do you need ProdOps?
Why do teams around the world
need an external company
to come in and help them
achieve that goal?
Because it sounds like,
today, you have DevOps internally,
you have different
scrum masters internally.
Why would I want an external firm
to come in and help me?
Okay. Because you find yourself
dealing with a lot of backlog around you.
You can always probably say,
"Okay. I have a lot of work."
"How do I start?"
"How can I create a different?"
Because I need to do the maintenance.
I need to do the work.
Okay. I can step back and look at it
from another angle.
And I need someone experience
that will help me to do it.
It's first.
Second, to overcome technical challenges.
It takes a lot of time.
It's not that you can call yourself,
you are a Java developer.
Great. So, you will know new stuff
that happens with Java, for example.
But it's not Java.
You have in cloud, native landscape.
A lot of tools.
And each one of them can, let's call it,
take you a step forward.
What tool do you need to use now.
How can you use a tool
that won't add complexity
more than it needs.
So, what it sounds to me is that,
the firm doesn't go in
and you're not completing JIRA tasks,
for the team.
You're not actually going in
and necessarily helping them
code the product.
But you're helping them
understand at a higher level.
How do the different products
within the company serve the customer.
How do you make sure
that the teams work official.
And how do you take a step back
and understand what are the priorities
that the startup or that the enterprise
needs to accomplish
in order to maximize on their value
for their customer.
Exactly.
And from time to time,
we also step into
the hands-on work itself.
And if we need to help our clients
to scale up his technical capabilities
in the delivery pipeline,
in the cloud infrastructure systems,
we do it as well.
Okay. So, how many people
are part of this group ProdOps?
We have 20 people.
Almost 20 people in Israel,
London and Miami.
Spread into three countries.
Why Miami?
Yes, it's a good question.
Okay. If you want good relationship
with the wife or your employee,
you need to have a career.
And Ziv, one of our senior directors
wanted to move to the US,
and his wife is a doctor
and she's accepted
to a Miami Beach hospital.
Okay.
So, it's not a bad reason.
It's not such a good decision.
But we live with it, so it's okay.
I love it.
Well, in covid time
Anywhere, they can work anywhere.
And I guess the only issue
is the time difference.
But I guess as an entrepreneur,
you're already very adapt
to working across time zones
and being awake
at all sorts of weird hours.
Now, I'd love for you
to take me back to your journey.
And before we started this,
you mentioned this idea
of bootstrapping and saying "no".
And saying "no" specifically,
to institutional funding.
Because here in Palo Alto,
all that I'm hearing all day is,
when are you going
to raise your next round;
and how quickly can you raise the round;
and how much money can you raise.
And it sounds to me like you have a story
that doesn't go along
with that narrative specifically, right?
It's only when you need the money
for growth,
you can do it by yourself.
What I think we foretell to ourselves
that we managed to create value
from almost the first day of our work,
and we managed, I think,
to do bootstrap for, let's call it,
for initiatives that we decided to do.
But we take small risks.
There is a price to it.
Okay, we take small risk.
We probably won't be able
to take bigger risk.
But it's good enough for us for now.
So, how do you manage
that balances an entrepreneur
between taking the money,
being able to go to high risk things
versus bootstrapping,
maintaining ownership
and control of the company
and in the decision making process,
but not being able to take
those big risks?
I will take them when I will,
and I think will know
that it's not eventually,
that it's really the green light for me
that I will be able to scale
because I have the money, okay?
Not because the business need it.
Not a good enough reason.
Okay?
Because I will, let's call it,
have more clients
and I will need more people to sell them.
Right. It's also not a good reason
because if I can sell them
and I can get money,
why do I need it, it's not my money.
Right. But what is the downside
of getting an institutional investment
and saying at the end,
Now I want to grow my team at ProdOps
from 20 people to 200 people.
And instead of serving a few clients,
I want to serve hundreds of clients.
Because it sounds to me like
you're convinced that you've reached
a product market fit.
And you're providing value
to these companies.
And you're learning
a lot from the process.
Then why not take that leap?
Because I think that our, let's call it,
mid management team,
is not ready for it right now.
Once he'll be ready,
I'll think I'll do it.
So, what you're saying here is that
there's this dilemma for an entrepreneur
where you also need to take account,
are we ready to be able to manage
a company at a greater scale
than what we have.
Are we ready both in terms of our product,
but also in terms of our management.
Yes. Internally, of course.
So, I can hire. Okay.
Of course, I can go and hire.
But it's not the way we believe
we can do a great, let's call it scale,
for ourselves.
So, one of the things
that institutional investors help with
is keeping the entrepreneur accountable
and keeping a reality check constantly.
Because they're not necessarily
emotionally invested into the idea.
But they're looking at the product
and the value that it provides.
So, how do you then,
as an entrepreneur and the CEO,
how do you keep
that reality check for yourself
without the help of the VC?
I have a good advisory board
and I have a good mentor.
I think it's always a good tip for anyone.
You need to have an external mentor.
And you're right to be able
to look at his eyes and say,
"Please give me the truth all the time
and check me."
So, I'd love to transition this
to the other part
that we talked about before,
which is mentorship and relationships
as you go along
this entrepreneurial journey
as one of the key milestones,
or cornerstones of an entrepreneur.
So, talk to me a little bit
about the importance of relationship
and mentorship in your eyes.
I think a good mentor
should always ask you the question,
"Is it still your goal?"
And if it's your goal, let's make sure
that every decision that you make
meets your goal.
Okay. I think it's one of the
main characters of a good mentor.
Second, if in his eyes
you're not in the best position
for your company,
and you're not doing the good job,
he need to tell you,
"You need to move. Think about it."
Consider to make a transition.
Consider how would you like to grow
from this now.
From this point.
Either way, I look at the good mentor
and those are the questions
that I keep asking my mentor all the time.
On every meeting that I think we have
about the strategic topics
that we would like to discuss.
Right. But we obviously
can't take for granted this idea
of finding a good mentor.
So, how do you go about
even finding the right person
to help you on your journey?
Because it's wonderful
to have that person.
But it sounds pretty difficult
to find somebody who's committed
to helping you as an entrepreneur
and giving you
that real honest and direct advice.
Because that takes time and effort.
It takes time and effort
to gain a trust with the person.
Gain a trust, I think
it's the main difficulty.
And believes that
he has added value for you.
I met my one of my great mentors
in a different work, let's call it
from Theory of Constraints Work,
if you're familiar with the practice?
I'm now. What is that?
Okay. Professor Eliyahu Goldratt
wrote a book, The Goal.
Maybe you're familiar with the name,
The Goal?
I'm not familiar. No.
Wow. Okay.
So, you have [--]
No. But yes.
Theory of constraints.
It's a management practice.
Company like Apple and Amazon
work by this practice.
And it's why
they're such a great companies.
Because they find,
let's call it the weakness,
in the whole chain of a process.
And they improve only the one bottleneck
that is the weakest, let's call it,
let's call it in this way,
they find the bottleneck.
Once they find the bottleneck,
they fix it.
And then they ask you,
"Okay. Is my process improved or not?"
It needs a person that I want in my life.
So, it's because you always keep looking
for the weakest things
that I have in my business.
And then he points on it,
I work very hard to improve it.
So, just to make sure that I understand.
This whole concept is that,
you're looking at your whole supply chain,
whether it's your life,
your business or product.
And you're saying,
"Out of the hundred things
that I'm doing,
maybe 20 of them are bad."
But what is the worst one
that is really stopping
my company right now from growing?
The weakest link.
Let's capitalize on that.
Solve that and then, remeasure.
What is our new landscape.
What is our, like now,
a hundred of different elements,
now, maybe 19 of them are just bad.
But what is the next weakest link.
And slowly take those out
of the equation, right?
Yes, it's a logical process.
And you need to deep dive into it.
And you need to ask yourself five whys,
and not one or two.
And make sure
that it's exactly what you do.
And not fixing the symptoms.
Right.
Why are you so excited
about the work that you're doing?
Why ProdOps?
Why helping teams with software?
Before we were talking about the impact
and the responsibility of an entrepreneur
for a better world.
So, why specifically
the industry that you're in
where you're helping companies
bring their idea to impact and fruition?
Obviously you could have gone
to a lot of different other paths.
Why did you choose this one?
I think because we helped much more ideas.
See the real world, really.
It's, what does it mean?
Go to production.
We know from our previous experience,
80% from your software goes to garbage.
Right? Right.
Because it's fun to see the day.
Daylight even.
And we help our customers really
to deliver their code to production.
It's not actually exciting
it's not the code in itself.
It's that we create, I think,
a business around it.
And serve people
and give them a better service.
I love it.
Okay, Viki, now, the hardest question,
which I did not give you enough time
to prepare for,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself,
or any of your clients would use
to describe yourself.
Who is Viki Slavin?
Okay. Someone trustful.
Okay. Why is it trustful?
I think, yes, people can trust me.
And I think I own this.
For 20 years that I'm in the business,
and different businesses that I did.
I think second,
I have high intuition.
I make decision by it.
I think, and [--]
that you didn't give me time
to think about it,
I take ownership on things.
And that's how we started
the conversation.
And that's how we're ending it.
I mean, that's inspiring for me to hear.
I completely agree.
I mean, at the end, taking ownership
and responsibility,
I think is the number one key.
It's not just entrepreneurship.
It's anything that you do.
And I think it's also the essence
of being a trusted person. Right?
Having other people know
that you take ownership over your actions
and over your words.
I think that's really inspiring.
Viki, one piece of advice
that you would give
to a rising entrepreneur
that is just on their path
as they go along their journey now.
I think it creates a positive environment
where people work, learn,
or spend their time.
Create a good environment for people.
Because if not, what are they worth?
So, I think they need to create
a good culture in every companies
that they start and establish.
And the way they grow supposed to be.
And create good environment
for your people.
Not good conditions. Okay?
Not good, I think opportunities,
or good money.
Just good environment.
I love it.
Viki, thank you very very much.
Toda raba. Best of luck with ProdOps.
Thank you very much.
Have a lovely day.
Take care. Bye bye.